here we go with game 11 that you just
saw come to a close officially crowning
magnus carlson yet again
as our world chess champion we had an
italian on the board and now that the
match is behind us you know what was the
what was the final
evaluation then here i guess you really
just give the nod to magnus carlson's
team for showing up prepare to play the
lopez and say come beat my marshall i
don't think you can do it ultimately
yawn was forced to go probing elsewhere
he tried in english now he tried in
italian and and what does that say again
about magnus carlsen's title defense and
the preparation and work his team did to
help him get that title yeah magnus team
deserve a ton of credit because they
chose variations that magnus was
generally speaking more comfortable than
jan that said maybe what this match
shows that jan had to choose more
aggressive lines things that weren't
just a slight edge that if he didn't
play every single accurate move it would
dissipate and magnus would be fine but
he played italian in the last game he
had to do something different and it
didn't work out for him but at least he
tried
it wasn't italian lucky for us we have
one of the world's leading experts in
this opening for either color sitting
right next to us his name is fabiano
carwana and bobby i'm playing through
the opening moves i guess the first one
that had us talking was right here
magnus committing to
what you highlighted as one of the big
decisions black can make on the queen
side between a6 and a5 well i think that
magnus had um
a clear and healthy plan of development
of course all all moves are possible
here a6 or a5 or h6 or castle there are
so many ways to play this uh but what
magnus did was extremely logical and
healthy
and
uh it felt like
jan's italian was sort of
a spur of the moment decision right i
don't think that it was prepared
in advance because it didn't it felt
like although he made logical moves he
didn't have
a plan of how to put
a lot of pressure on magnus yeah so uh
we we saw what we kind of predicted
knight c2 bishop e3 was a very logical
way of approaching the position
it also led to
a very very
slightly better wide but pretty close to
equal position right yeah and one where
you know magnus could make healthy
developing moves and not feel under too
much pressure and i think
like bishop takes e6
at this moment not the best way to fight
for an advantage bishop to e5 felt like
if there's an advantage to be found it's
only after bishop to b5
uh i still feel like it's it's very
close to equal yeah
but uh this would have been more
ambitious approach and
in the game it at this moment it started
to feel like magnus is equalizing the
position his opening has been a success
he came into this game
only needing a draw for it to be a good
result right he
he's so far up in the match
was so far up in the match that uh
any draw and even said this any draw is
a good result it takes it closer to
overall victory so he was happy with the
result of the opening
yeah and and the only thing i'll add is
in real time robert had been
suggesting potentially this as well you
mentioned a4 and bishop b5 after bishop
e6 by carlson perhaps this was another
way to keep it spicy uh and maybe try to
induce a4 forward right robert yeah at
least there could be a target later in
the game i don't think it actually
amounts to an advantage for white in the
immediate position but at least there
are some long-term efforts and as the
game continued instead of queen b3 with
a4 i did like what yan tried right he
went for this position he did get his
queen to b3 of course black went b6 and
then he went h3 knight h2 so
as this developed it left black with a
difficult decision but magnus was well
prepared not in terms of before game
preparation but for this moment that he
didn't have to rush a decision he'd have
to play d5 which we saw could get him
into some difficulty in some of these
lines instead he played the simple queen
d7 rook to d8 and made sure that he was
ready to strike in the center when the
time came
and strike in the center he did
obviously we spent a lot of time
calculating some
uh potentially other ways jan could have
kept tension queen to b5 was a
suggestion a move earlier
perhaps instead of knight h2 uh
obviously fawn when she joined us
pointed out that maybe just the simple
queen d8 is actually just totally fine
for black so so shout out to iphone for
that but
really i guess knowing what we know now
about the position it seemed that even
before committing to this plan of h39 h2
fabi that yawn had maybe miscalculated
the critical moment that is that is
coming up here very soon i think it's
entirely possible he has saw this d4
idea in advance when he played h3
uh
and he thought that this would lead to
an advantage for white
based on the line we saw in the game
uh where black plays unusual moves rook
to e4 and rook to f4 are quite unusual
you usually don't see rooks on these
squares especially when it's in white's
territory and potentially attacked by a
lot of pieces and queen c2 we saw that
attack so i think he saw us in advance
and rook to f4 came as a surprise maybe
he was expecting d3 and a sharp fight
there
uh where black regains a4 plan but white
suddenly gets a very nice stable center
with c4
and uh
or even trying to corral that rook
slowly with g3 and b3 so he was probably
happy with
with this uh
in in his calculations far in advance
and when rook to f4 happened he looked
uh
unpleasantly surprised and this is the
moment where
he had he had a chance to to go for a
drawn ending and we all were expecting
that
and just to show that drawn ending it
would have occurred after rook d4
rook d4 cd4 and knight d5 and at the end
of uh
a massive simplification when the smoke
clears
what you see is what you get something
that is is uh
dead drawn and headed for equality and
apparently not to yawn's liking
enough so enough so not his liking that
he played the move
g3
yeah and that move isn't really playing
for a win as we saw in the game was
actually very easy for magnus to play he
could make a draw at any moment and it's
white's king that's in danger so i think
that jan because of his recent struggles
he sort of has had enough i was saying
that perhaps he should have just made
the draw he would have to win three
games in a row that wasn't going to
happen but at least it gave him an
opportunity to really play for a win
whereas this was playing for a loss yeah
and again playing for a loss is a really
hard thing to say and and we won't go on
and on about it obviously we expressed
our sentiments with with the utmost
respect for for yon upon mishi but also
again just very surprised because magnus
showed it at the board this is
regardless of the fact that it ended up
taking a rookie to get there this is
clearly
a a losing move after he takes f3 and
queen takes she for the
the result the dissolved not the
dissolve the result was never in doubt
from here yeah i think that ian going
into this position when he played g3
understood that this must be losing
but he probably thought the task of
winning three games in a row two with
black
against magnus
was an impossible one and
he is correct in that uh i mean
we thought it was impossible but it
still feels better to make good moves
even if you know that those good moves
will only lead to a draw
and probably to the end of the match it
leaves you with a better feeling i think
when you play you know accurately and
and it didn't work out rather than when
you play a move like g3 which is
objectively bad
and leads to
um
a position like this where magnus had
his choice of winning attempts and
didn't even find the fastest one yeah
here we pointed out e takes f2
queen takes f2 is only move because king
takes up two queen h2 is that
skewer we saw with the queen gain loss
and rook to d6 unstoppable threaded work
to g6
white can block it but only with the
queen
and white loses that queen and the game
because the material deficit is so
enormous at this point
so
to be
honest it's it's a bit this is the most
obvious
uh way to win but for some reason the
move which came to everyone's mind i
think was knight f5 we were supposed to
just suggested it uh i think he found
also
uh felt like this was the natural course
and then also magnus played it yeah and
yon found a nice shot at keeping the
game going
but we're already talking about
trying to hang on for a few more moves
because objectively white
will lose a lot of material in the
process of trying to save his king which
is exactly what happened
yeah d6 was a fun little shot uh
surprisingly very hard move to play uh
because you're not an engine you're a
human just taking the pawn and then
continuing the attack was probably best
for black but instead robert he took the
forcing line
uh f takes e3 note let's note the fun
line that giving this check and queen h2
check would actually be a very bad idea
because of a pretty fun shot at the end
of the line
yeah
black's still doing well because of rook
takes d1 and the queen end game should
be good but it's a problem to allow
someone to queen with check especially
when you were supposed to see up a queen
so instead of that of course magnus
played accurately and he entered a rook
end game that was actually quite
instructive because he was only up one
pawn after this precise sequence and he
said i have the open file the only one
on the board i have this outside past
pawn that eventually became a queen and
he just didn't give white any
opportunities to exchange the queenside
pawns as we were highlighting during the
game if the three pawns on the queen
side for each side were traded the game
becomes a theoretical draw so as we came
to this moment here we are looking at
lines where it has to strike with b4 and
that's exactly what jan did but magnus
showed great accuracy to put this rook
behind the apon and make sure that there
was no rook c4 c5 and then a5 that would
be a critical move for white to dislodge
the defender and then start training the
pawns but because the rook's an a2 the
rook would just capture the pawn a5 and
that ends all of white's play
because of that john's hand was forced
yet again
he decided to go for the most direct
aggressive approach activate the king
and and see if we get some counter play
but magnus accurately calculated that
the h pawn would ultimately be too much
and as it came up the board
one last critical decision to make
possibly f6 and g5 was a a slightly
faster winning attempt but magnus took
the uh the safe approach the one that
felt good to force the queen on the
board
and it wasn't uh wasn't long right i
guess a good lesson in technique here
right because a lesser a lesser man
might have messed this thing him up
there's there's some tricky uh
opportunities for white if the pawn does
reach a7 but a centralized queen
is uh is black's best friend here yeah i
think this end game is is far from
simple
and although magnus made it look very
especially with this nice queen to e4
move and we saw later the nice king to
g7 move uh just one inaccuracy and it's
very easy to imagine white saving this
game uh and i'm sure queen e4 was seen
in advance
and probably the reason he made the
decision to go for this rather than f6
which also seemed pretty good
uh was because he saw queen e4 and white
has no
good way of coordinating the pieces if
white could get asics a rook in front of
the pawn like rook be at a7 then we're
already talking about black taking a
perpetual trying to make a draw but
white can't coordinate the pieces here
and
they played the rest of the moves pretty
pretty quickly because i think they both
calculated
um
that white has no good options except
for what john did yep
which was probably the best chance but
uh but not sufficient
it's a good lesson to note that the
queen in the center constantly
threatening forks ways to uh to win to
win the white rook again examples like
here you can't just continue to push
things uh this queen e6 here would
attack the rook and pawn the work has to
go behind the pawn to defend it
otherwise the pawn is lost and then we
see the common tactic of picking up the
rook so very instructive and precise by
magnus carlsen and enough to ultimately
win the game when he found the move
queen to c5 pushing the pawn would lose
the rook and everything else
gets closer to black simply creating a
new pass pawn and winning the game and
with that
the last coinbase rapid recap of the
2021 fide world chess championship comes
to an end
chess.com's coverage of the 2021 feed a
world championship is brought to you by
our partners at coinbase whether you're
just thinking about making your first
crypto purchase just wanting to learn a
little bit more about the crypto
industry or if you've been doing this
thing for years and you're an
experienced trader coinbase is the place
to be
visit coinbase.com chess and get five
dollars in free bitcoin just for signing
up and verifying your account today we
really encourage you to do so go check
them out at coinbase.com
[Music]
you